all right d'angelo
d'angelo uh where'd you grow up where
you from originally i was born in new
orleans louisiana
um raised in las vegas nevada came out
this way after hurricane katrina you
know so i'm basically west coast
and you're currently based in l.a or
vegas no las vegas nevada but i've been
back and forth from los angeles in las
vegas
since 2012 since i got out of prison and
uh
because of my other baby mom she she's
from swans she's from out here then i
have another baby on the way with my new
baby mom and stuff so that's why i'm in
california other than that
i'm vegas bam and your new baby mama is
faith who i interviewed a week or two
yes ma'am
i mean yeah sorry and uh
you're you're a gang member yes sir
which which gang i'm from west side
playboy bloods
17 21 kyron white see your blood
and uh tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were a kid no
sir my
um my mom um when she was born
when basically when she was pregnant
with me she had lupus cancer so
she ain't had no strength for her legs
and stuff basically due to the drugs and
stuff that she was doing
when she was pregnant with me she had
observed this cancer so
they told her that i was never going to
be able to live or whatever so they
started giving her steroids and stuff
and
she kept doing drugs and stuff and when
i was born in 1993
in new orleans she she basically got the
the cancer took over her body more and
she started
like losing her cells and hair started
falling out so
as everybody else as a kid growing up
knowing their mother and their father
i had to go see my mother at a hospital
all the from my
from all the way up to 2001 when she
passed like i never seen my mom like
regular like
anybody else like that go to the store i
always got to see my mom on the hospital
bed
even to the day she died so and my
father i don't even know of him i know
of his name but i don't know him
and but he's of chicago a native out of
chicago
a gd i don't know him he ran out on my
mother when she was pregnant and
pretty much i was just raised by the
streets and stuff once my mom
passed away in 2001 family took me only
because it was a state check when she
was
she worked for the state before i was
born so once i
mean when she passed the family felt
like only reason for me to be around is
for
they can accept this check so it really
wasn't no love i was just there
for a check you know so especially the
streets raised me
you joined the gang at what age uh i
started gang banging like around six
years old sir
six yes sorry wow
and you you done prison time yes sir
what kind of stuff got you in prison
um you said well god what did you say
what would you do to get in prison um
and
i was i was uh involved with uh one of
my friends he's
he's he's just now getting released now
uh
we have basically committed a uh act it
was a murder but
a conspiracy to murder um a friend of
ours
we were young you know and through dumb
stuff i had stole a car
and um we had seen the guy that who had
shot my friend
a few weeks ago and had shot his sister
on the school bus
and me having a young mentality ways and
not thinking and just like
thinking i'm young and tarranted not
giving a damn i basically provoked my
friend into
let's go hurt this guy like he hurt your
brother like so while you still got him
walking type stuff so
i provoked him and to like bestie like
basically how do you say the word like
um
um um ah when you like basically when
you
you trying to get somebody to do
something and they don't want to do it
basically yeah basically that's
basically what i did he really didn't
want to do it but i was so amped up and
angry at the situation i'm like yeah you
can go do this
yes sir so we drove down a little street
dark street we seen him walking on and
i told him to hop out and start shooting
he hopped down and started shooting and
the guy lay he he he died basically you
know and
they caught me later on throughout like
a few weeks later through my friend
because he told
me which he was supposed to because it
was wrong
you know and all actually we know at the
feeling like we think we're gangsters
and all that but we all know right from
wrong yeah
that was wrong and i felt like i needed
to be caught and i got
caught you know when i was 15 at the
time and started fighting as an adult
in the state of nevada they had nevada
revived statues and that's nrs so they
have their own laws so
you can go to prison as a teenager in
the state of nevada
and i was released when i was 18 which
was 2012 and
came out here to california and been
living both lifestyles but
i haven't been game banking no more or
nothing sorry after that life
situation right there i started off real
young and stuff like real real young and
i'm 27 now how did you meet faith
i met her through off um
basically off the on the website man on
facebook man you know i usually don't
even be clicking on my friend
requestings
and i so happen to just clicked on the
friend request i said you know when you
see the pretty white girl or something
it's fake facebook or something you know
so i'm like damn let me go i'm bored you
know
tripping with my baby mama anyway let me
go ahead and click on this and see if
it's real i clicked on the boom she
messaged me
i'm like oh this fake this is why you're
one of them arabian people in other
countries with fake facebook accounts so
i'm like damn
so i clicked on it boom i messaged her
like where are you she like i'm in
california city
i'm like whoa i've been in california
city before boom so i'm like damn that's
crazy so
we started connecting and talking over
the phone first thing
she believed that i won't go come get
her and come see her in person which is
the show you believe is catfish you see
on mtv
so i had to come show her what is real
you feel me access granted i had to pull
up
on the process of me getting to her i
had went to jail
for my partner he was speeding in
roseman i went to jail
she believed i flaked on her and all
types of stuff so she was believing like
to show catfish he's not
real he's not coming so i ended up
getting out coming back to l.a county
getting on the train and actually
getting a ride to cal california city
and that's when i actually met her no
no no no i actually met her she was
already gone out of california city she
was in vegas waiting on me
and that's when i actually met him when
i went to vegas and that's when we met
so faith will do business in both vegas
and
l.a yes and as her boyfriend you're just
kind of
you you do you do what you just oh man i
hustled man i got a hustler's heart you
understand man i'm from new orleans man
like
we we can't sit around broke you know
like not even broken especially the
society of the world we live in
it's two reasons to come outside make
money and spend money if you ain't doing
that
ain't no reason for you to be breathing
or coming outside you're just a bad
entity
and that's what us as a people need to
surround ourselves around good positive
people that's willing to make money and
spend money
we get ourselves caught up throughout
the day around people that's not
with none of that on their mind it's
just straight demonic stuff you know
so we got to keep forward and keep our
mind on
a hustler's standpoint you know a heart
like keeping money in our pocket you
know
somebody needs something in need help
them you know
just having that godly spirit in us you
know because all of us are not perfect
you know
and we we just got to have that good we
all know right from wrong
so that's my my my goal every day as you
know is to make money and spend money
if it ain't that i'll try to stay away
from all these type of entities get away
from them people
the [ __ ] is all bad people all
right man
then you have a baby in the way yeah
baby on the way another one that's
my fourth one man fourth one did you
raise the other
kids did i raise other kids me
personally with like how most people i
i never got the opportunity to raise
none of my kids like
because of the lifestyle i live like
this is my first time just
settling down with women and actually
having girlfriends and stuff
and cause i was really into the gang
style and
into really taking the life and to
really making the person not
exist no more like that's what my whole
motto until i started learning and
expanding my brain and and realizing
it's a point of life and not just taking
other people's lives and
listening to other people's situations
and reacting off of their situations you
know
so do you have regrets over some of the
things you did yeah sorry
yes i regret everything got it done like
i i pretty much i learned to point in my
life to where
i i started blaming a lot but again i
learned to
not blame it take the responsibility for
my actions you know so
whatever i do i take responsibility of
my actions now but
i used to i know i used to do the
self-pity me thing and
feel sorry let me feel sorry for me and
all that i don't
i don't have that in me no more like i
learned to
take advantage of my own situations and
take
take take responsibility in my own
actions you know and
not blame others for nothing i don't i
don't do crimes with other people
i don't do anything i never told on
nobody
in that situation but i've been told
long before but
how does karma play a role in your life
it's big it's big karma is a big big
thing
you know big big big big big big woman
she's a big [ __ ]
yeah like you know big big biggest [ __ ]
you know on the street you know like
that's why i try to treat her as
as good as possible you know like cause
karma she come out of nowhere her big
ass just hop in the street just
she hog up traffic yeah you know like
and i'm that taxi driver you know i'm
not stopping i'm that new york taxi
driver i can't stop it's too much going
on
too many people you know so i try to
treat people how i want to be treated
you know
and try to keep a smile on my face even
though i have an evil look you know but
god is good you know
and what's the now that you're out of
the gang life
um and you have a child on the way what
do you see for your future
man i see i see a lot you know like
i see my own business you know i just
need to get this money right and start
saving money you know like but
the society we live in you got to spend
some type of money but
i need to learn myself to start putting
like 100
to assad three hundred dollars to assad
and just
put it in the sock or something act like
something wrong act like it's some bill
money or something because
i spend a lot of money wherever i go i
spend money i don't hold on to money i
don't even like money it's the root of
all labels so i'll spend it
are you working or do you have a job or
anything i don't have a job right now so
i'll hustle sorry yeah
which i have my id now and i'm in the
process of trying to get my social
and everything but everybody got these
family-owned businesses now
due to corona and to shut down all the
major corporations and stuff so
i mean all the small businesses so the
major corporations can come in
and take over you know but again it's
just something i'm thinking about and
doing you know i'm trying to start my
own business you know once i
settle down at which i am settled down
you know to get my life on the right
track which it is
i just need to surround myself around
more positive energy
you surround yourself around 10 broke
[ __ ] you going to be the
15th broke purse feel me so i'd rather
surround myself around
a lot of positive people that hate me
and despise me and everything
but it's still going to rub off good ore
because i'm around positive people even
though they hate me you know
and that's what i learned to not let
people i don't care what they say of me
you know
because that ain't that's one of our
sins we're cursed with
sin we're not even supposed to see you
know so not even the religion in there
and all that is just
that's one of my things i know of life
like so i
i don't take this looking and seeing me
looking and everything's a curse so
i know when it's that time i'll be
forgiven for me saying you know
if anybody understand what i'm saying
you understand that
are you in love with faith yes sir
that's my whole world see the reason i
walk around and i get up every day with
a smile and
and and motivation into doing anything
positive
and and i have a baby on the way and
she's a beautiful woman
she's smart she's intelligent and she
just put herself down through because of
the situation she's been through you
know and i try to
let her realize like it's him is on his
earth and the time we're living in
everybody's mind is expanding and
opening up and this is what god's people
he's expanding he's blessing us with you
know so that's why i'm trying to get her
to realize that i'm one of god's
treasure you know and
i'm really wondering are you comfortable
with her
going out and making money the way she
does without you personally that
lifestyle me personally i know i hate it
you know and me personally i hate it and
i hate
i hate pimps i hate people like that
forced women to do that but again
when a woman needs to do that i feel i
feel like she needs to keep her money
for herself
and if she is doing that she needs to
keep our money for herself and build
herself up instead of
getting used and her giving that money
to another man that don't even know her
and that's basically using her and
basically he has a whole lifestyle at
home
he's not forcing his baby mom to come
out there and do this
that who has his kids you get what i
mean it's a cycle women like
don't know their values you know like i
be damn if i'm a prostitute and i go
down here and i'm making money for
another person i got to give it to him
and his kids and his family and stuff
and i'm not good with myself and i don't
even have nowhere to stay you know what
i mean
so it's just a psychological game and
people those men attack women
like that's low low self-esteem they
don't care about themselves don't want
to go out
like when they go outside they feel good
about themselves or something because
they feel like somebody like somebody
told them they were beautiful today
you know somebody told them they were
sexy somebody turned around with that
extra look or something you know
they feel good about that instead of a a
man always telling what they need them
to do and
this is how they get money you know so
me personally i don't respect that game
you know but i respect
the hustle of getting the money part
other than that the the giving the money
to the man
and like you know him holding on to the
money
you're an adult you can make your own
money you're the one who made it you'll
be dumb if you give your money that make
him like saying like you
he's a human accountant that's crazy i'm
i'm but it's a very dangerous lifestyle
dangerous it's real difficult
you're okay with her going out at night
no sir i'm not okay i get nervous and
everything every time man it's just
that's her free will pimps have the
thing your arm will pimp and all that
because you're forcing someone there's
pimps and then there's hustlers and i
think there's
there's a fine line yeah different more
you know and if that's
how she feel like she gets her money and
she want to do it that's her bill
i'm my myself no don't go out there and
do it
like me personally i'll rob and kill and
steal but i'm learning
better and to expand my mindsets better
ways than getting money you know
and you guys you guys are staying in
motels right now yes sir and when the
child comes what do you think you'll you
guys will do
uh well i'll have a by the end i have
you know i have an apartment by the end
you know and everything because i'm i'm
pretty much in this like
this program with the gr thing and
hoping they come through with me it's
called a pilot program
where they help you with the apartment
and especially the homeless out here
they help them with apartments from the
people that's really trying to get
apartments you know that's not playing
with them
and then so that's pretty much what i'm
gonna do get into the pilot program so
that
i can get them to have an apartment for
myself and my newborn you know so i can
actually take care of my child
now that i have you know because i never
got the real opportunity to even sit
there and take care of the child my past
baby moms because of situations you know
and i think it's a blessing that i have
so this would be your fourth child
yes the other three are with the baby
miles and
how many two or two of them are in the
system how many different baby mamas do
there's only two
two two women and two of your kids are
in the
foster system to um one of them is not
really my my kid i i basically took
like she was pregnant with him and stuff
and i loved her so much and me being the
type of man i am
i'm not gonna leave a woman out there
that she feel me especially if i'm
messing with her i know she's pregnant
but i know it's not mine
so when the child was born i picked the
child put my last name on the child
you know yeah so i consider her as mine
too you know
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
27 years the most important lesson i
learned in life
period is the loving yourself
they trick us every day with reading
school
everything else distractions vibration
music to love other things
to make us forget about ourselves period
ourselves like
this is how they control the world like
to get you to
idolize something else a tattoo a image
false energy
we do all these things we got to do this
and worry about all our things
throughout our day and we forget about
ourselves and our creator
and that's where we get ourselves messed
up to where we hate ourselves and
we image the the media the entertainment
the tv we idolize those things but we
don't love ourselves so
the biggest thing in my life is learning
how to love myself and
put a smile on my face you know and keep
that you know cause a lot of people hate
that you know
and and we forget that we're we're
spirits you know that's how your heart
is beating and that's how you
that's how i'm looking at you and that's
how i'm communicating with you so
i said it's a blessing that i learned
how to love myself and
find out the truth of life is just
loving yourself and they give you the
tools every day
with vibrations bust all the things and
vibrations and
things to get you to forget about
yourself you read a book you're reading
about something else
you're not worried about yourself so my
biggest thing is self-preserving loving
yourself and
loving yourself whatever it is they feel
bad about they said they don't love
their self
so that's why they they have that you
know and that's not right
and they trick you with those you know
and they tell you to go to these
programs aau
that you sick and that you know all the
way there and all that but you're not
crazy you're good not crazy you know
nobody crazy that person that that's
speaking to himself he's not crazy
it's just his spirit is lost right now
demon ain't nothing but a
trap entity that god already got us out
of here straight back
you know on the right and everybody
that's done that's why i walk
and she get mad at me when i walk past
people and i tell a random person man
love yourself you got a beautiful
you beautiful out here and the person to
look at me crazy like damn
what is he talking about love yourself
man they tricking you every day to not
love yourself
get you away from your creator love
yourself you don't love yourself you
gonna fall for anything
you're gonna start thinking about other
things you're gonna idolize work you're
gonna take on other energy
start yeah man i don't like you because
you don't love yourself you know you're
supposed to love yourself
wake up in the morning damn i love what
wash your face that's where that mirror
is right there so you can look at
yourself oh i'm right there get these
eye boogers out my face
brush my teeth you know you know to love
yourself we don't even do that in this
timeframe we wake up
smoke a cigarette or something or
listening to the news coronavirus
cover up stuff like that god is good man
he's giving everybody the strength and
the tools
to get back with him but again you
remember in the spiritual warfare man
where
the evil was going to try to outdo the
bad but you need bad to do good
i ain't no motivation it's not even that
it's just i found out the truth man
loving yourself
you